I can't do anything I'm pushing buttons
on it's not moving son of a Matt no no
[Applause]
oh there it is ow there it is
I kind of regret doing this video now oh
this is a great segment idea I love this
[Music]
round one fight
[Applause]
round two fight
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Johnny Johnny
Mr Walsh
good to see you sir uh hey how you doing
how have you been okay so what are we
doing here so in front of you we have
the new Mortal Kombat game that one just
came out today
not sure if you remember two years ago
you and I played a similar version of
this who are you again
well uh before you called me a
production assistant Jacob PA Jacob yeah
now I am Professor Jacob Michael Knowles
is associate producer
I lost my honor two years ago when you
beat me at this game okay yeah I
remember this it was two years ago it
was and I remember
I won three three out of three matches
many people said it was the greatest
Mortal Kombat performance they'd ever
seen in their lives
yeah many people said your performance
was the worst they'd ever seen in their
lives and so there's that kind of
dynamic it was very interesting yeah you
know I had never last time I played
Mortal Kombat was when I was like seven
and you played all the time and I and I
crushed you I that's what I remember
happening I I okay I don't want to say I
play all the time I but today I'm gonna
regain my self-respect okay and this and
have you practiced at this game have you
played it before
a little bit a little bit do you want to
choose your character I'll choose mine
and hop right into it uh okay which one
am I
you are I'm blue no I'm red yeah what
color is that orange I think it's orange
okay
they've got the controllers without
cords now
they do how long has that been going on
for a little over a decade okay
I think I want to be the black the black
chick here what's who's she looks like
her name is Tanya I can't say I know her
personally but uh I don't know is that
the more Progressive choice or the or
the Le or the or culture appropriation
for me to be the black woman so I'm
gonna be her you're going to be who
Johnny Cage Johnny Cage
okay
now you get to pick a teammate here so
someone to help you out with your combos
wait what yeah so there's going to be
two people in the fight when you do a
combo they come in and they help you
with the combo to do extra damage well
we're gonna do an interracial thing here
I think
Striker
[Music]
is the gayest character I've ever seen
in my life all right
so Striker's gonna hang out in the back
and when I call upon him he's gonna
exactly now you get to choose where we
fight
uh let's do the fire temple the fire
temple I need a new bodyguard you eye
around what what a video game system is
this a PlayStation five PlayStation 5.
teammate has a gun that can't be fair
[Applause]
round one fight
oh wait remember that push Circle
what did I press that made that happen
uh like everybody hang on this tells me
the moves
those my moves are yours I'm not
controlling uh those are yours try to
push Circle
uh
there you go now when you push Circle
again we'll go back to fighting so if
you want to look at these first you can
check them out Heavenly hand
enhanced Heavenly hand
down rights
Square
I can't even read that R2 R2 yes where's
R2 this button right here on the right
side on the bottom
okay I don't know why I'm helping I
shouldn't be helping you I should be
looking at mine well you know I'm at a
disadvantage here
okay just let me in the face of the bump
oh sorry
put a circle again
there you go
Superstar
right in the nuts
am I winning
oh no I don't think I am wait time out
time out time last time no you said time
out last time and then you punch man not
falling for that again we're not doing
that
[Music]
there's no freaking way
because she's a strong black woman she's
taking you down
son
there's no way
not again
bro what is happening I don't know how
that guy keeps coming in but
wait time out time out
there's no way there's no way there's no
way
hang on
it's okay there's three rounds it's okay
I uh I gave you that one I felt bad you
know I yeah look at that wait wait a
second
I keep see
can I just emote I didn't mean to do
that
oh my God how do I I can't do anything
I'm pushing buttons out it's not moving
it's not moving look at this I can't do
anything
no no that's all yeah look at that
bringing the other guys look at that oh
oh time out time out
you can't keep saying time out it makes
sense
all right I got a hand cramp I have a
hand cramp hang on
time out time out
just gonna keep pushing the same button
over and over
yes I'm just gonna keep walking
there's no way there's no way I refuse
to believe it
did I just win I won again
that's it right listen listen that
thank you
[Music]
've ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider to actually stop people
from monitoring your online activity you
need to do what I do and use expressvpn
think about all the times you've used
Wi-Fi at a coffee shop Hotel even a
friend's house without expressvpn every
site you visit could be logged by the
Admin of that Network that's still true
even if you're in incognito mode
Expressway pen is an app that encrypts
all of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
your private online activity stays
private expressvpn works on all your
devices it's super easy to use the app
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Walsh YT use my Link at
expressvpn.com Walsh YT to get three
extra months free that's exp ressvpn.com
walshyt it's best out of three so don't
just you jumped the gun last time you
didn't want to play again last time that
was just what do you mean best you want
me to play three more times of that
absolutely that's exactly oh hell we
didn't we didn't agree with that do we
agree on that we we we we all
collectively so that's like
that's so what is it we have six that's
like six matches
what yeah nine rounds
okay
just if I lose is there asterisk on this
one just so we know yeah if I lose it's
not legitimate if I win it is okay
so that's your problem the guy's too
cocky
hang on a second
wait
you gotta give me a second good setup
why is it that every time you say wait a
huge attack comes like right after it
no you can't keep bringing your guy in
like my guys like your guy with the
pistols my guy runs in he's got a gun he
runs in and just slaps you your guy has
a gun mine is a guy with a hand that's
smoking a stogie it's not the same level
yeah
look at he runs he doesn't do anything
horses oh my God use your gun you dumb
son of a
no that's not fair that doesn't count
that one doesn't count
[Music]
who did that was I died or something
that doesn't count doesn't count doesn't
count doesn't count
I was just not gonna say anything I'm
not gonna say anything I don't want to
get too cocky fight
oh oh I know your knee hurts okay well
now my whole body
[Music]
I love this combo you can't you can't do
anything I'm just kicking in the
forehead give me something Matt get out
of the way oh
that doesn't even make sense
look at your health bar
s okay
right in the nuts again
I'm sorry Matt the buttons
oh look at that look at it
this is this is rigged this whole thing
is rigged
I didn't come in mentally prepared to
play this many times I didn't I
my whole strategy was based on my whole
strategy was based on one game my whole
strategy ahead of time well last time
you flexed about button smashing so I
think you should just stick to that this
time hopefully it saves you again
because it's a tiebreaker
if you want to check your controls one
more time
you're going to hop into it I know what
I'm doing okay all right got undefeated
in this game all right
[Music]
I wish I knew how to do what I'm doing
[Applause]
okay this doesn't even count this
doesn't count I already won
this part we're not even gonna put this
in the video
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is right
stop blocking and actually fight yeah
let me just take Howard and just take
the sword strike to the face real men
don't block in fights
yeah you just blocked like well she's
not a man is she so
foreign
you go on the offense for once
doing all the work over here
they'll stay away
there you go
I have some of that why don't you
wait a minute
hang on can we stop saying I'm just
trying to see I'm trying to see
something
stop blocking stop just pushing the same
button
all right
it's coming down to the wire
even though this doesn't count anyway no
it doesn't count it doesn't count
oh man
fight
let's just moonwalking
a second
it doesn't feel good does it oh look I
don't know how you can't do anything
right now oh there we go there's the
block oh it's how do you like that
I wouldn't know I ducked under it
did you pause it or did I pause it that
was definitely you Matt okay hang on
we we need to have a serious
conversation about what this video even
is
oh man all right yeah I gotta put this
back on because I'm getting I don't even
know where I put it man why doesn't need
a bandana because it's getting serious
now and I need to get into the Zone I
just like evaporated Into Thin Air did
the bed damages disappear
[Music]
oh no
oh you're so cheap for that
oh my gosh McKenna for sure did that on
purpose there's no way
all right look you still got like two I
didn't I didn't know that you weren't
flying oh yeah
you are shooting me
if that doesn't kill you then what's the
[Music]
name
no bro
no bro there's no way
oh
you're so that look at that
Matt stop it stop it no
listen to me that was the chick that's a
victory that's a victory your producer
asked me so hang on wait a second
[Music]
I
last played Mortal Kombat when I was
seven came out of retirement at the age
of 35 Flawless victory
I'm pulled out of they're not going to
retirement again I'm pulled out of
retirement a second time this is like
Michael Jordan
and I come I come back
you're all cocky you're ready to go
and I beat you
and then you tell me we got to play some
more so now I come out of retirement a
third time actually and I win again so
that's what actually just happened
that was like an inside job with your
producer to help you win and I'm not
gonna you know what keep your head in
the game you're all worried about your
uh a bandana
keep your head in the game it's a lesson
it's a lesson for life so I teach my
kids all the time
stay focused on what you're doing
I don't even know what to say
I
you can say congratulations
that's what you say
there it is
fatality